Well, let's go. Let's talk about Moore's law a little bit. It's, uh, uh,
at the broad view of Moore's law,
where it's just exponential improvement of, uh, computing capability,
uh, like open AI, for example, recently published this kind of
papers,
looking at the exponential improvement in a training efficiency of neural
networks for like image net and all that kind of stuff,
which has got better on the,
this is purely software side is figuring out better tricks and
algorithms for training neural networks. And that seems to be improving, uh,
significantly faster than the Moore's law prediction. You know?
So that's in the software space.
What do you think if Moore's law continues or if the
general version of Moore's law continues,
do you think that comes mostly from the hardware, from the software,
some mix of the two, some interesting, totally. Uh, so not,
not the reduction of the size of the transistor kind of thing, but more in the,
uh, uh,
in the totally interesting kinds of innovations in the hardware space,
all that kind of stuff.
Well, there's like half a dozen things going on in that graph.
So one is there's initial innovations that had a lot of headroom to be
exploited. So, you know,
the efficiency of the networks is improved dramatically.
And then the D composability of those [inaudible], you know
, they started running on one computer, then multiple computers and multiple
GPU's and NRAS the GPU's
and they're up to thousands. And at some point, so, so it's sort of like there
were consumed, they were going from like a single computer application to a thousand computer application. So that's not really a Moore's law thing.
That's an independent vector. How many computers can I put on this problem?
Because the computers themselves are getting better on like a Moore's law. Right
. But their ability to go from one to 10 to 100
to a thousand, you know, it was something and then multiplied by the amount of
computes it took to resolve like Alex net to resonate
to transformers. It's, it's been quite, you know, steady improvements.
Those are like cars aren't, they, that's the,
exactly the kind of cars that are underlying Moore's law from the very
beginning. So, so what, what's the biggest, what's the most, uh,
productive, uh, rich source of S-curves in the future?
Do you think, is it hardware? Is it software?
So hardware is going to move along relatively slowly,
like, you know, double performance every two years. There's still,
I like how you call that slowly. It's the slow version,
the snail's pace of Moore's law. Maybe we should, we should,
we should trademark that one.
Whereas the scaling by number of computers, you know, can go much faster,
you know, I'm sure at some point Google had a, you know,
their initial search engine was running out a laptop, you know, like, yeah.
And then at some point they really worked on scaling out and then they factor
the, the indexer from, you know, this piece and this piece and this piece,
and they spread the data and more and more things. And, you know,
they did a dozen innovations,
but as they scaled up the number of computers on that, it kept breaking,
finding new bottlenecks in their software and their schedulers and,
and made a rethink. Like,
it seems insane to do a scheduler across a thousand computers who scheduled
parts of it and then send the results to the one computer.
But if you want to schedule a million searches, that makes perfect sense. So,
so there's th the scaling by just quantity is probably the richest thing.
But then as you scale quantity,
like a network that was great on a hundred computers may a completely the wrong
one.
You may pick a network that's 10 times slower on 10,000 computers like per
computer. But if you go from a hundred to 10,000, that's a hundred times.
So that's one of the things that happened when we did internet scaling.
This efficiency went down, not up.
The future of computing is inefficiency, not efficiency,
but scales and efficient scale.
It's scaling faster than efficiency bite you.
And as long as there's a dollar value there, like scaling costs, lots of money,
but Google showed Facebook showed everybody showed that the scale was where the
money was at.